-White House Press Secretary,
Sarah Huckabee Sanders,
has been holding a lot
of press briefings lately.
But I don't think all
the questions we need answered
have been asked.
So we decided to hold another
one right here, right now.
That's right,
Sarah Huckabee Sanders
and the "Late Night" press corps
are here in our studio
and ready to go.
So without further ado,
it's time for the "Late Night"
White House Press Briefing.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Sarah? Sarah, yes, Sarah. Sarah?
[ Reporters shouting at once ]
-Sarah. Yes, thank you.
Seth Meyers,
"Late Night with Seth Meyers."
Secretary Sanders, how would you
describe the Trump Presidency
in three words?
-Russia's unfortunate decision.
[ Laughter ]
-What does
the White House staff say
when Trump starts tweeting
on a Saturday?
-This will be
a working weekend.
[ Laughter ]
-Donald Trump's approval rating
keeps spiraling to record lows,
with most polls showing it
below 40%.
Do you think it
can fall any farther?
-15% has been the goal.
It's always been the goal.
We're gonna continue
pushing for that.
-Best of luck.
What do you think
President Trump still needs
to learn in order to get better
at his job?
-8th grade civics.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
I heard you accidentally made
eye contact
with Ivanka Trump the other day.
How did that go?
-It seems like a kind face.
But when I looked at her again,
she spat on me.
[ Laughter ]
-What role is
Eric Trump playing
within his father's
administration?
-He'll work with
the groundskeeping crew
here at the White House
and will help cut the grass.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Secretary Sanders,
complete this Meatloaf lyric.
I would do anything for love,
but --
-The President's not willing
to do that.
-Close.
[ Laughter ]
Very close.
How is Betsy DeVos doing
with learning the alphabet?
-There's a long way to go.
-Okay.
[ Laughter ]
Is it true that Donald Trump
is considering
the Mad Hatter to be the next
Federal Reserve Chairman?
-We're not gonna go down
rabbit holes on personnel.
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-What does Vice President
Mike Pence call sex?
-The Privacy Act.
[ Laughter ]
-Do you think Satan exists?
-He wrote the President
a letter earlier this year.
[ Laughter ]
-Has the President's stance
changed
on what his favorite
Pink Floyd album is?
-He's still 100% committed
to "The Wall."
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
[ Laughter ]
[ Applause ]
What do you like better --
legs or feet?
-I think both of those parts
are very important
moving forward.
[ Laughter ]
- What was President Trump's
reaction to Ted Cruz
liking that porn video
on Twitter?
-He watched the entire thing.
[ Laughter ]
-Ted Cruz denies that he was
the one who liked that video.
So if it wasn't him, what kind
of porn does he like?
-A lot of strong women
in various positions.
[ Laughter and cheers ]
-How would you describe
Jared Kushner
in seven words or less?
-Inspiring 11-year-old
young man.
[ Laughter ]
-What do people need
in order to realize
that the President is unhinged?
-Access to a working phone.
[ Laughter ]
-What's the sentence
that terrifies President Trump
the most?
-Let's get to work.
[ Laughter ]
-Follow up -- what's the biggest
thing you have in common
with your predecessor,
Sean Spicer?
-I hate to do this.
-[ Chuckles ]
[ Laughter ]
And finally, a question
that I
and I assume my colleagues
have been dying to ask.
How does an orgy work?
-As I've said several times
earlier today,
the goal is to have everybody
come together.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I told you. I told you guys.
I told you.
Well, it looks like
we're out of time.
So on behalf of the rest
of the press corps,
have a good night.
[ Cheers and applause ]
We'll be right back
with Kyra Sedgwick, everybody.